this is literally the most San Francisco
scene in the history of San Francisco
you've got a guy with a guitar but god
of the scooter stuff for sale in the
street and a delivery robot almost
running over a dog
but this robot is on a mission somewhere
in San Francisco a human is hungry for
Mediterranean food order from truly
Mediterranean and the Mission District
through Yelp eat24
and you might get a text message asking
you if you'd like a robot to deliver
your food and of course you do so
instead of dispatching a human to your
house the staff loads your order into a
robot called marble and off it goes once
it gets to your pad you input a special
code to unlock it sensors in the storage
area detect when you've removed your
food
sigelei to the robot it's time to move
on uses cameras and lasers to observe
the world around it as it makes its way
from the restaurant the customers home
and there you have it
food delivered to your door without an
ounce of actual human interaction as you
can see navigating a vibrant and chaotic
neighborhood is a tall order even for
humans so while the robot is
semi-autonomous a human chaperone has to
walk alongside it to remote-control it
if it gets confused our robots design in
such a way to perceive most fully the
crazy urban environment they're
operating within so we have this multi
sensor approach similar to self-driving
cars we're utilizing lidar or laser
scanners on top as well as cameras sonar
another such sensors while self-driving
cars navigate relatively organized roads
delivery robots have to deal with the
unrelenting unpredictability of
sidewalks the problem is humans before
being real humans get in the way humans
get annoyed emissions but humans are
also mesmerized by robots yeah the the
interactions we've had so far been have
been wildly positive people are
incredibly uh insurance by the robot and
they are surprisingly helpful you know
if you're thinking well what's to stop
me from pulling my truck around and
stealing the robot which I'd say good
luck a human will be remotely monitoring
the robots at all times but the big
question is does this make any sense why
can't humans keep delivering food on
their own Marvel says their robot will
allow restaurants to deliver food around
the clock and with robots making short
runs in the immediate neighborhood human
drivers can focus on deliveries farther
away yeah so if your robots is as
complementary to the pre-existing driver
networks because there are certain
certain type of order that makes sense
for one of these robots one that fits
within our shorter range in size
constraints venture capitalists seem to
be convinced they're pouring mountains
of money into several different startups
all working to transform the delivery
business with robots still for the time
being these robots have big limitations
they can't climb the stairs for instance
and they get stucked hence the human
wrapper but they may be the first
glimpse at a future where we share more
and more space with the machines
delivery robots or otherwise just be
sure to give them some rope
[Music]